économie en déroute finances publiques
aux abois tunis s'apprête à demander son
quatrième prêts au fonds monétaire
international
depuis la révolution de 2011 un prêt non
sans conséquences pour le pays qui devra
s'accompagner de réformes drastiques de
privatisation de licenciements massifs
dans la fonction publique que lui j'ai
été le principal syndicat tunisien
compte bien négocié les nombreux plans
des d'internationaux accordé depuis plus
de dix ans n'ont pas suffi à redresser
le pays qui souffre toujours d'un sous
développement chronique avec un chômage
qui touche près de 2 actif sur cinq
une fois n'est pas coutume c'est auprès
du fmi et pour la quatrième fois que
tunis se tourne après avoir obtenu de
l'institution de bretton woods une
facilité de paiement de 616 millions
d'euros l'an dernier
la tunisie il souhaite aujourd'hui une
rallonge assez importante 3 5 milliards
d'euros remboursables sur trois ans
objectif boucler son budget et sortir de
la spirale du surendettement
je peux confirmer que les équipes du
fonds ont rencontré les autorités
tunisiennes plus tôt cette semaine et
celle ci ont fait part de leur programme
de réformes économiques
nous sommes prêts à aider la tunisie le
peuple tunisien à lutter contre l'impact
de la crise à progresser vers une
reprise inclusive et à restaurer des
finances viable à washington jusqu'au 9
mai la délégation tunisienne va devoir
apporter des garanties mais surtout se
plier aux doléances du fmi notamment en
matière de réforme condition sinequanone
auprès l'une des mesures phares et de
remplacer les subventions des prix est
des produits de première nécessité comme
le pain par des aides directes aux
familles un projet qui n'est pas du goût
des tunisiens qui reproche au
gouvernement de s'attaquer aux acquis de
la population autres projets et réformer
le secteur public
et c'est bien là le coeur de la gangrène
tunisienne il faut savoir qu'en tunisie
les dépenses qui est la fonction
publique ont toujours été
disproportionnée avec un nombre de
fonctionnaires bien trop élevé par
rapport au nombre d'habitants et aux
besoins du pays
ces dépenses représentent plus de 10 7%
du pib chez l'un des niveaux les plus
élevés au monde
à titre de comparaison la france elle
consacre 13 % de son pib aux salaires de
ses administrations pour ce faire
quelques pistes se sont à l'étude
départs à la retraite anticipés elle
travaille à temps partiel
restructuration des entreprises
publiques lourdement
endettés comme la compagnie aérienne
nationale tunisair ou encore la steg
société tunisienne d'électricité et de
gaz
tunis entend contenir la masse salariale
autour de 15 % du pib en 2022 contre
17,4 pour cent du pib en 2020 selon un
rapport obtenu par l' agence
france-presse
avec un déficit budgétaire qui a triplé
en 2021 11,5 pour cent du pib et une
dette à 100% du pib national
la tunisie n'a d'autre choix que de se
tourner vers les instances
internationales quitte à se plier à des
conditions drastiques sans réelle marge
de manoeuvre surendetté à genoux et au
bord de la banqueroute le pays semble
n'avoir plus d'autre choix que de se
plier aux exigences du fonds monétaire
international pour peut-être espérer
sortir de cette crise économique et
sociale sans précédent